Using the beautiful soup module, we can take all this code that we wrote fairly
painstakingly in the first three units of the class, and I know that now that
you're a fairly experienced programmer, it doesn't seem too hard to write this
code. But this code is actually very fragile. It only works on very specific
ways of encoding link targets and we can replace that with much simpler code
that uses far fewer lines and works much better. We're doing that by importing
from bs4 which is a BeautifulSoup library. The BeautifulSoup definition, which
allows us to create an object that represents a web page. Here, we're passing in
the contents of the page just like we were doing in get all links. And the
BeautifulSoup module provides definitions that give us a very easy way to
extract all the links from a webpage. In the first part of the course where
we're writing this code ourselves, but we wanted to really understand how to do
things and our goal is to learn about programming. If you're actually trying to
solve problems, you're much better are finding a module like BeautifulSoup,
where someone has already put a lot of effort into figuring how to do this in
the right way and written a tool that works much more robustly on much more
complex web pages than the code we wrote this. So, modules are a real big win
and we can use this without worrying about it polluting our namespace because we
know the only name that we've imported here is the name BeautifulSoup. And we've
replaced these 18 lines of code with 6 lines that if you understand what the
module does, are much easier to understand and much simpler than having to
understand all 18 lines and they work a lot better. So, modules are a huge win,
they make it very easy to share code. And one of the things you should be
thinking about as you develop more programs, especially if you're developing
them to actually solve problems, not just to learn about programming, if there's
a module that already exists that you can use to make your coding much more
simple.